of america joe biden was here
and all of you are here give yourselves
a round of applause
we are all here because this is the
moment
and this is the place are you ready
[Applause]
there is something special happening
in this state
i can feel it there's energy on the
ground
there's hope on the horizon
there's change in the air can you feel
it
the people are rising up
to claim the best in the american spirit
the sacred covenant we have with one
another as an
american people e pluribus unum
out of many one we are
one people we are one america
and here's what we've got to do
we've got to fight hard
because the future of our nation depends
on it
we've got to push back against the
demagogues of hatred
and bigotry and fear
beware of folk who try to frighten you
into reelecting them
the truth is that's right winnie skirt
[Music]
the truth is
they cannot lead us and so they're
trying to divide us
they have no vision so they traffic
in division we need visionary leadership
we need moral leadership we need
competent caring and compassionate
leadership we need joe biden
and we need a graduate of an
hbcu kamala harris
we need raphael worldwide
and we need john myself
[Music]
and so tell all of your friends if you
haven't voted
you got to show up and vote as john
lewis my
late and beloved parishioner used to say
we've got a vote like we've never voted
before
now i know that most of you if not all
of you have already voted but make sure
everybody in your circle votes
make sure your family members vote make
sure your friends vote
if you're single and somebody asks you
for your phone number tell them i don't
date people who don't vote
this is serious business
this has been a long and painful period
but we are about to write a new chapter
in the american spirit in the american
story
and i'm proud just to be a part of it
because my story is a part
of the american story can i tell you my
story
i'm rafael warnock candidate
in the special election for the united
states senate
georgia is the only state with two
senate races
up for grabs my friend john ossoff
is running for one he is a crusader
against corruption
we must elect him
i'm running in the other seat
i'm one of 21 people in my race
21 names on the ballot
listed alphabetically my last name is
warnock so i'm
near the bottom the name
next to the last name
i'm near the bottom but that's all right
because that's where i was born
i was born near the bottom yet i'm
standing on this stage running for the
united states senate
it is a testament to the promise of
america
and the grace of an almighty god
born in poverty i was raised in the
public housing projects of savannah
georgia
we were poor but i feel like i hit the
jackpot
because i had parents who loved and
nurtured me i had
a village that protected me and believed
in me
i'm one of 12 children
obviously my parents both preachers read
the bible and took it
rather seriously be fruitful and
multiply
i'm number 11 out of 12
and the first college graduate in my
family
[Music]
i often say that i went to morehouse
college on a full faith scholarship
that means i didn't have enough money
for the first semester
but i went on to earn my degree and went
on to earn a phd degree
and 15 years ago i became the pastor of
ebenezer baptist church
spiritual home of martin luther king jr
and the great john lewis
now that took a lot of grit
hard work determination
personal responsibility yes
but that alone did not get me there
somebody gave me a pell grant
somebody gave me some low interest
student loans
in other words i had a path to a
prosperous
and more productive life we must vote
tomorrow because it's harder now for
children
growing up in urban centers in atlanta
and in disaffected rural communities in
north
georgia than it was for me we must vote
tomorrow
because student loans have now surpassed
credit card debt and auto loans too many
of our children have a mortgage before
they have a mortgage
we have to vote for all of our young
people and so i'm running
because as a pastor who has stood up
time and time again
sometimes in acts of civil disobedience
trying to get our elected leaders to
expand medicaid
i understand that health care is a human
right
and that it is certainly something that
the richest nation in the world can
provide to all of its citizens and
georgia deserves a senator who believes
that health care is a human right
[Music]
we should have recognized long ago
that we need all of our neighbors
covered
but now that we are dealing with a
deadly
airborne disease my neighbor coughs
and that potentially has implications
for me
i should want that person covered
i should want their children to have
access to a good quality education
i should want to make sure that their
parents can retire with dignity
in other words we're tied in a single
garment
of destiny the other day i was
down in a small town in southwest
georgia
where their nearest hospital had just
closed
devastating rural health care jobs going
away
people devastated while politicians are
playing games
and the young man stood up in the town
hall and he said reverend
i wanted to meet you because i've heard
about the work you've been doing in
criminal justice reform
he said when i was 18 years old i went
to prison
but i got myself together i learned the
lessons
i've been out of prison now for 15 years
i'm a popular dj in the community i've
been telling other folk to vote
and they didn't know that i was telling
them to vote because although i've been
out for 15 years
i haven't been able to vote because he
lives in a state where we keep people on
probation for a long time
we use all of these tools to keep some
people from being able to vote
he said but after 15 long years and a
hard fight
i finally got my franchise back and i
can't wait
to vote for you
[Applause]
and so my beloved as i close and nobody
believes the preacher when he says as i
close
we must stand up and we must vote for
him
we must vote for others like him
we must vote for the people we now call
essential workers
but we don't pay them any central wage
we don't provide for them essential
benefits
we must vote for our seniors who have to
choose between
buying food and buying prescription
drugs
we must vote for all of our children
because
none of our children are safe until all
of our children are safe
we must vote because your vote is your
voice and your voice is your human
dignity
we must vote because a vote is a kind of
prayer about the kind of world
that you want to live in and prayer is
stronger
when we pray together so vote together
and pray together
and stay together and struggle together
and work together
and together we win god bless you
georgia
god bless america tomorrow we win
[Music]
[Music]
um
change
ladies and gentlemen please welcome john
[Music]
ossoff
hello atlanta
[Music]
can y'all hear me in the back
thank you for being here on this
beautiful day
it is truly an honor
to run alongside my friend a moral
leader for our state and for our country
give it up again for reverend rafael
warnock y'all
and what an honor for all of us today
here in georgia to be joined
by the 44th president of the united
states
barack obama
[Applause]
president obama is here with us today
because georgia
in the midst of this terrible crisis
the eyes of the nation are on us
and the message today is simple
the only way out of this mess y'all is
to vote
like we've never voted before
[Music]
we're living through a health and
economic crisis
unlike anything we've seen in our
lifetimes
the american people are suffering
this pandemic has taken nearly a quarter
of a million american lives
millions have lost their jobs our daily
lives
have been upturned and at a moment when
we need
steady competent leadership
we're getting nothing but chaos
incompetence
deception and division right now as we
speak this pandemic continues to spiral
out of control
we will only defeat this virus by
electing competent leaders
who care about our health who can unite
our country
to rise to this moment who will empower
doctors and scientists
to guide us out of this health emergency
it didn't have to be this way
it didn't have to be this way
but president trump and senator david
perdue haven't just failed us
they've lied to us every step of the way
senator perdue told us kovid 19 was no
deadlier than the flu
he told us this virus would have little
impact on our economy
he knew better
he was getting private briefings in
washington
and while he lied to us and downplayed
this pandemic
he was busy taking care of himself
and his own stock portfolio
meanwhile senator perdue and president
trump have silence suppressed and
attacked the very medical experts
whose expertise we need to contain this
pandemic
georgia hundreds of thousands
of our fellow americans neighbors
friends parents and grandparents are at
risk
if we don't vote tomorrow to make a
change
and elect people who care about our
health more than they care about
themselves
look what we want what we need what we
deserve
it's not that complicated
the first exposure i ever had to
anything like public service
was working for congressman john lewis
may he rest in peace
congressman lewis taught me about what
he called the beloved community
a place where we recognize that we're
all
rise or we fall together y'all
the beloved community is a place where
every one of us has access to affordable
housing
affordable health care education without
debt
dignified work that pays the living wage
equal justice
under the law regardless of race and
regardless of class
that's the beloved community
and we can build it
but to build it we've got to vote
to build it we need to elect brilliant
decent
compassionate leaders remember not too
long ago
we were led by a man who put our health
our prosperity
our interests ahead of his own
president barack obama served this
nation for eight years with conviction
with compassion with competence with
integrity
president obama recognized that we only
rise to historic challenges such as this
one
when we come together when we focus on
what we have in common
rather than what we have apart president
obama
recognized and helped us to see that
america's journey is bigger and more
ambitious
than political parties or partisan
rivalries
georgia it's up to us to elect leaders
who will heal the wounds of these last
four years
reunite this country lead us out of this
crisis
and build a stronger healthier more
prosperous
and more just united states
and tomorrow is the last chance
to make our voices heard
55 years ago congressman
john lewis led a march across the edmund
pettus bridge
in selma alabama and he had his skull
cracked by a billy club
for demanding the right to vote
and what we are seeing right now in
georgia
is that whatever obstacles are put in
our way
we are determined to exercise that
sacred right
to participate in our democracy to vote
like our lives depend upon it because
they do
so i'm asking you georgia
honor congressman lewis legacy take
nothing for granted
make a plan to vote tomorrow call your
friends
your neighbors your cousins your
colleagues from bankhead to buckhead
from the coast to columbus from the
mountains to the florida line
make a plan to vote it's time to restore
the soul of this nation
it's time to send david perdue into
retirement
it's time to send carolyn bordeaux to
congress to re-elect lucy mcbass
to elect senator kamala harris the next
vice president of the united states
to elect joe biden to lead us out of
this crisis in the white house
it's time to vote like we've never voted
before
thank you so much georgia i love you
thank you
[Music]
i need your energy
i need your energy
this world is killing me
light it up
[Music]
[Music]
i need your energy
i need your energy
this world is killing me
light it up if you feeling my feet light
it up
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
temple douglas
[Music]
good afternoon atlanta
my name is temple douglas and i am a
sophomore at the university of georgia
[Music]
i was born and raised in columbus
georgia and graduated from hardaway high
school
i was also a proud girl scout for many
years
and part of being a girl scout means you
have to take the girl scout promise
it's the promise to treat people around
you
and in our world with compassion i don't
know about you all
but i believe we all need more
compassion love
and kindness right now and we need to
have a leader in the white house
that brings people together not divides
us
joe biden and kamala harris will unite
our country
they believe in making sure that all
americans from
every walk of life have opportunities to
succeed
and they believe in treating people with
respect
love and kindness the hate
rhetoric and lies coming out of the
trump administration
scare me it makes me worried for my
future
and the future of our country and
community
the growing racial divide and tension
has only been exacerbated by president
trump
but it is time for a change when i was a
little girl
i remember my father got involved in
politics and started working on
president obama's campaign
i was only eight years old at the time
but i was greatly inspired
and i knew history was being made and
all of my fellow young people
that are fighting on the front lines for
change are ready for that momentum to
continue
i got to cast my vote early and for the
first time in a presidential election
for joe biden and kamala harris
and i'm filled with so much hope about
change for the future
there is so much at stake in this
election from women's rights
to lgbtq rights to climate change
joe biden and kamala harris know that
young people are leading the way
on the issues most important in this
election
joe biden and kamala harris also
understand that representation matters
and will appoint cabinet members and
justices
that represent the diverse population in
the united states
starting with the office of vice
president with madam
vice president kamala harris
[Applause]
we are truly in the battle for the soul
of our nation
and we will win but only if we continue
to engage
mobilize and empower our generation to
vote
tomorrow on election day we have to vote
as our lives depend on it because they
do
so everyone please make a plan to vote
tomorrow
tell your family your friends and your
neighbors
and even the person parked right by you
right now
we have a real chance to finally flip
georgia blue
but that can only happen if we have the
energy and enthusiasm
from young people like us across the
state
to mobilize and get out the vote and now
it is an honor to introduce the 44th
president of the united states
and one of my personal heroes president
barack obama
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello georgia
[Music]
can everybody please give temple a big
round of applause that's the kind of
young people
that are going to lead the way oh i am
excited
thank you for arranging for good weather
it is good to be back
i've got one word for you atlanta
tomorrow
tomorrow after four years
of failure you have the power to change
america tomorrow you can put an end to
the politics
that tries to divide a nation just to
win an election
it tries to stoke conspiracy theories
and
and fear at a time when we need
confidence and we need hope
tomorrow is the most important election
of our lifetimes
and you can deliver the change that we
need
but you're going to have to vote if you
haven't dropped off your ballot yet
please do not wait any longer
if you voted already help your friends
and family find their polling places at
iwillvote.com
help them make a plan to vote
tomorrow because this election is going
to take every single one of us
and right here in georgia
you've got an even bigger power to
deliver the change that we need
you can be a state that sends joe biden
and kamala harris
to the white house
[Applause]
[Music]
i got a chance to campaign with joe over
the weekend and it felt like the old
days
for eight years he was the last one in
the room whenever i faced a big decision
he made me a better president and he's
got the character and the experience to
make us a better country
and he and kamala are going to be in the
fight not for themselves
but for every single one of us
but if they are going to deliver the
change we need
getting this pandemic under control
restarting our economy
protecting our health care protecting
our planet reforming
our criminal justice system giving every
young person a
equal chance then they're also going to
need
a senate that actually cares about those
[Applause]
things
so georgia not only can you put joe and
kamala over the top
but you can be the state that gives us
all
a better chance because you've also sent
john
ossoff and reverend raphael warnock to
the united states senate
[Applause]
yeah i didn't originally plan to come to
georgia
you know you you see all this gray hair
i got
you know i'm i you it still looks good
you said
uh
i'll i'll let michelle know
but but the reason i'm here
look i i thought
after my last campaign in 2012 i thought
all right you know
i'll campaign in 16 and then i'll just
kind of go off and
you know write my book and work on my
golf game and
spend a little more time with my wife
things didn't work out the way we
expected because
we weren't focused each one of us didn't
do
everything we needed to do
and so in this election when i got a
call and said look georgia
georgia could be the state georgia
could be the place
[Music]
where we put this country back on track
and not just because joe biden and
kamala harris have
a chance to win georgia but you've got
the chance to flip
two senate seats i said well i got to go
i got to come
[Applause]
i told michelle i'm sorry baby i
i got to go to georgia this is a big
deal
you have two extraordinary candidates
in john and the reverend who deserve
your vote
and let's face it you've also got two
senators who badly need to be replaced
[Applause]
look i i served in the senate
i remember when we used to get briefings
in the senate
for threats that including
the kinds of briefings that your two
current senators got
about covet 19. they got briefed
you know you go into this room and it's
all
top secret and you got to kind of close
everything off and
you know you can't take anything out of
the briefing room because
this is part of your responsibility as a
public servant
and the point of these briefings is so
that
you can take quick action to protect the
american people before it's too late
that's why
the senate gets these special briefings
to serve
the interests of the people who have
sent you to washington
to serve their interests before your own
when i heard that your two senators here
in georgia
and understand what i'm about to say now
is not a partisan statement
i'd be just as hard if i heard a
democrat was doing this
your two senators publicly were telling
you that the virus would be no big deal
but behind closed doors they were
making a bunch of moves in the stock
market
to try to make sure their portfolios
were protected
instead of making sure you are protected
man that's shady
that that's i mean that that's
that ain't right
they downplayed the pandemic in public
and in private they're trying to see if
they can profit
profit from it both of them not just one
on both of them
they're like batman and robin gone bad
it's like the dynamic duo of
doing wrong
i don't know what they were thinking but
georgia i promise you
georgia was definitely not on their mind
[Applause]
it was not and and what's the result
of betraying the public's trust
230 000 americans are dead
more than a hundred thousand small
businesses
have closed almost 200
000 jobs are gone in georgia alone if
president trump and your senators had
been focused
on covet from the beginning instead of
their portfolios
or their tv ratings
cases wouldn't be reaching new record
highs across the country just this week
nine months into the pandemic
america just had the single worst week
of new cases
think about that all the people who
voluntarily quarantined
all the folks who've been working at
home all the the
the the mothers and fathers who've been
looking after their children at home
trying to keep everybody safe and
after all that we saw the worst week
because
we had people like your two senators who
were not taking it seriously
we had a president who was pretending
it was just like a bad flu
and now trump's chief of staff finally
admits what we've known all along
he was quoted just just a few days ago
he said
we're not going to control the pandemic
well yeah we notice you definitely are
not
but you know what joe biden and kamala
harris
can get on top of this pandemic
[Applause]
and if we've got two new senators from
georgia we can have a government
that's making that happen
what's trump's closing argument right
now you know
last night on his covet spreader tour
he's going around spreading covert
he's like a carrier
because he cares more about having big
crowds than he does about keeping people
safe
he told his supporters don't tell
anybody but he's going to
fire dr fauci after the election
we had signs up a couple days ago
halloween and said
had had a ghost on there said don't boo
vote come on
so just in case you were worried that
trump had been taking covert too
seriously he's now
he's he's stated publicly he's going to
fire the one person
in the administration a carryover was
also the president
when i was in there helped me deal with
ebola and h1n1
was one of the people who was at the
front lines
of dealing with hiv aids one of the
world's leading
experts on infectious disease one of the
few people in this administration who's
been taking this seriously all along and
what'd he say
his his second term plan is to fire that
guy
i mean they've already said they're not
going to contain
the pandemic now they want to fire the
one person who could actually
help them contain the pandemic
so georgia if you think they've done a
bad job at managing
covet so far basically what they're
telling you now is you ain't seen
nothing yet
trump's saying he might you know in this
election he's been saying he might
declare victory before
all the votes have been counted well
that's just what he did on this virus
and how'd that turn out
listen america deserves better than this
georgia you deserve better than this
[Applause]
you really do and here's the good news
tomorrow you can choose
something better tomorrow you can send
john ossoff
and reverend warnock to the united
states senate
and they can team up with joe biden and
kamala harris
and get on top of this crisis
yes we can
[Music]
[Applause]
let me just just in case just in case
you're unfamiliar
with the track record of the two
outstanding
candidates for senate that you've heard
from
john ossoff's life has prepared him to
serve as your senator
he learned about public service from my
dear friend one of my
lifelong heroes john lewis he's
dedicated his career
to fighting injustice he knows we need a
new voting rights act
that makes sure every georgian is
treated equally under the law
that makes sure every georgian can
exercise
the right to vote that people like john
lewis bled
for john austin runs a company
that investigates crime and corruption
around the world
which sounds like something we could use
in washington right now
[Applause]
that's like kryptonite to donald trump
and those corporate lobbyists that he's
all put in his cabinet
it's like water on the wicked witch
you remember
john's wife alicia is a doctor
she delivers babies and like so many
doctors who've been risking their lives
to save others
so many nurses and health care workers
on the front lines
alicia's been putting herself at risk so
you know that john's not going to
go around accusing doctors of trying to
profit from the pandemic you heard
that's what trump said right
he said well doctors are exaggerating
this because they just want to make more
money
these doctors these nurses these health
care workers they are in there
they are exposing themselves to this
disease
they are more at risk than anybody
and john ossoff understands that because
he's seeing it in his own family
he's going to listen to the experts and
work with joe biden to get this pandemic
under control
with a plan to make testing and vaccines
free for every american and make sure
our frontline heroes never have to ask
other countries
for the equipment they need because it's
going to be here
right there ready for american workers
and you know the other thing john's
going to do is he's going to protect
your healthcare
there have been more than 9 million
cases of covet-19 in america
and even for folks who get better
your insurer could could still consider
covet 19 a pre-existing condition
which means you might not be able to get
insurance next time
if the protections that we put in place
10 years ago with the affordable care
act
were eliminated republicans love to say
right before an election they're going
to protect your pre-existing conditions
listen with the affordable care act joe
biden i actually did it 10 years ago
those protections are already in place
we required insurers to cover your
pre-existing conditions
and since then republicans have tried to
repeal or
undermine the affordable care act more
than 60 times
they've promised don't worry after we
repeal it we're going to replace it with
a really wonderful plan
every two weeks for 10 years they've
been promising a new plan
have you seen this new plan i haven't
either
nobody's seen it you know why because
they don't have a new plan
they've just attacked the affordable
care act at every turn
[Music]
and in the process driven up costs
driven up the uninsured
now they're in the supreme court trying
to get
the supreme court to take your
healthcare away in the middle of a
pandemic
why would you do that
to just despite me
why why would you why in the middle of a
pandemic would you offer nothing but
empty promises
and try to kick people off their health
care
georgia something got to go
it's either your senators or your
healthcare
if i were you i'd choose your health
care get rid of the senators
who are trying to take it away you know
your senators aren't going to stand up
to protect it
they love to talk tough like president
trump
but one of the things they have in
common with them is when you start
calling them out
they cut and run
you saw president trump he he he's in
the middle of a 60 minutes interview
he just walked out it's too tough he
quit in the middle of an interview
somebody's asking him well what are you
going to do in your second term that's
too tough i'm leaving
and then you saw it again last week when
john ossoff
called out senator perdue on health care
in their debate
purdue was like one of those chickens
[Music]
i would have felt bad for the guy if he
hadn't voted four times to take away
your
pre-existing conditions protections four
times he voted against it
they were supposed to have another
debate last night
purdue chickened out pulled out
the scariest halloween costume he saw
this year was john ossoff in a debate
[Applause]
but let me tell you what's really scary
georgia
republicans threatening to end
pre-existing conditions protections for
100 million people
in the middle of a pandemic that is
scary
and you have the power to do something
about it
john also and joe biden will protect
your health care they will expand
medicare they will make insurance more
affordable
for everyone and so will reverend
rafael warnock
let me talk about the good reverend
right now
i won't preach but i will offer
testimony
this is a man who preaches at ebenezer
baptist church
in the pulpit of its great pastor dr
king
he's read the gospels and they may they
might not have known
about pre-existing conditions back then
but the reverend will tell you jesus
spent time healing the sick
caring for the poor when georgia
republicans fought
against expanding medicaid to cover
hundreds of thousands of your fellow
georgians
reverend warnock followed the example
of john lewis and got himself arrested
getting into good trouble
reverend warnock's life prepared him to
live in service to others
he doesn't just talk the talk he wants
to walk
here's a man who grew up in public
housing in savannah with 11 brothers and
sisters
that's a lot of brothers and sisters
that taught him a little bit about
working together
by looking out for others
about sharing his mom spent her summers
as a young woman
picking cotton and tobacco his dad was a
veteran
and a small businessman who preached on
sunday so he knows about
the power of opportunity and the
god-given right
to dignity and decent wages for working
people
from warnock earned his degree at
morehouse a morehouse man
but he did it with the help of pell
grants and student loans so
you know he's going to fight for every
single young person
who dreams of a college education but
doesn't know how he or she's going to
pay for next semester's classes
he's been there
last time i saw reverend in person was
at ebenezer baptist church for the
memorial service for john lewis
and he possesses the moral courage john
did to question what
to question right and wrong and call
things for what they are
and he's got the moral clarity to shine
a spotlight on injustice and make the
powers that be
uncomfortable and we need some folks who
will shake things up a little bit
and he's going to lead us in washington
to overcome
our own complacency and our own fears
and our own prejudices to become better
truer versions of ourselves
who he is and that's who we all need to
be
look we got we got
one day left i've been making a lot of
arguments out there
some of them should be obvious
and yet i know that there's still people
out there who
aren't voting so i want to talk to you
right now the people of georgia
right now who who've decided not to vote
maybe you don't like who's in the white
house right now but
you just lost faith in government you're
frustrated you don't think government
makes a difference maybe
you're troubled by what the two current
senators in georgia have done but
you're not really confident or certain
about
how much of a difference it'll make in
your lives
and i understand that government's not
perfect
government doesn't solve every problem
we've got a long legacy in this country
of hardship and prejudice
and people who are powerful and rich
taking advantage of folks who aren't
and we have a history of
we have a history right here in georgia
that john lewis spot
and others spot
and sometimes i can get down michelle
can get down sometimes we're at dinner
table we're just like
lord why are we still
fighting some of these battles i thought
we settled some of these arguments
i thought we had turned to corner
why why why are we still hearing people
praised
folks who think that the color of your
skin determines your status
why are we still acting as if
women shouldn't be treated the same as
men
and and paid the same for doing the same
work
why why are we having these old
arguments i thought these were done
it can be discouraging sometimes
and you drive through some neighborhoods
in atlanta or chicago or washington d.c
or you go out in some rural areas and
some small towns and you think you know
what
folks are still having a hard time and
some of the things that should have been
fixed haven't been fixed and you get
discouraged
i i i get it
even as president of the united states
there were times where i thought man i
want
i thought i could get this done or that
done and somehow
the the special interests and the
lobbyists and others are blocking it and
making it hard you get frustrated i get
it
but you know what whenever i get in one
of those moods i just remind myself
that
when we work together when we
put in a little bit of effort things may
not get perfect but they do get better
when when when john lewis started
marching across that bridge
it didn't eliminate racism and bigotry
in america but
it started something that got the voting
rights act passed
and it made things better
i didn't get everything done that i
wanted to get done when i was president
but
i could say when i look back at the end
of eight years you know what the country
is better off now than it was when i
took office
[Applause]
20 20 some mil million people have
health care that didn't have it before
that's a good thing
children that were in poverty have been
lifted up out of poverty not all of them
but
some of them that's a good thing
maybe this next generation
came up and saw that you know black and
white
can work together that we don't have to
be at odds that
that we can treat each other with
dignity and respect that
that we don't have to be scared of each
other but should reach out to each other
a president by himself can't solve every
challenge
in the economy but if we elect
people like joe biden and kamala harris
if we
elect reverend warnock and john ossoff
who are focused on working people and
getting
you the help that you need it can make a
difference
for thousands of people and ten thousand
people hundred maybe
a few million people might be better off
a president by himself can't eliminate
all racial bias in our criminal justice
system but
if we elect district attorneys and
states attorneys and sheriffs
who are focused on equality and justice
it can make things
better
john understood this dr king understood
this
abraham lincoln understood
george washington understood it
we knew john
i remember talking to john lewis right
before he passed
and we talked about all these young
people who had come out to start
uh this wave of of marches
nonviolent peaceful protests all across
the country
and we talked about how
this younger generation they don't have
to choose between protests and politics
if we're going to translate our
aspirations into laws and practices
we've got to engage in both
there's nothing un-american about
protests this country was founded
on protesting against injustice that's
what the american revolution was about
john ran for office all those years
and kept protesting even while he was in
office because he understood they're two
sides of the same coin
it's us acting on behalf of our
highest aspirations even though we know
we won't get there
we're never going to get all the way to
the promised land
but but we can help lay the path
for future generations to get there
that's what public service should be
about
that's what citizenship should be about
that's what voting is about
not making things perfect but making
things better laying
that path brick by brick to a better
future
putting us on track so that a generation
from now two generations from now three
generations from now we can look back
and they we can say
you know that was a moment when we
turned towards our better angels to our
our better impulses
where we started to pull together as a
nation
instead of being riven apart
and the fact that we don't get 100 of
what we want is not a good reason not to
vote
we've got to keep at it
you know typically just over 50 percent
of us vote
think about that almost half the people
who are eligible typically do not vote
and yes part of this is because folks
make it hard to vote
your governor right here in georgia
seems to make it his job to come up with
ways to make it
as hard as possible for some georgians
to vote
these folks sure are scared of folks
voting aren't they
think about that if you've decided you
don't
you don't want to vote don't you wonder
why it is that the folks in power
are so worried about you voting
there must be a reason why they try to
make it hard for you to vote
because they know if you vote things
change
the answer is not to stay home it's to
turn out like never before
and show them what's in your heart
show them the spirit
of community
imagine a 60 of us voting imagine if
70 of us voted not 100 just
70 imagine january 20th when
we swear in president biden and vice
president harris
and reverend warnock and john assad are
in the united states senate
imagine having leaders in office who
have a plan to get us out of this mess
and who care about working americans and
have a plan to help you
start getting ahead who believe in
science
and have a plan to protect this planet
for our kids
who believe in racial equality and are
willing to do the work to bring us
closer to an america where no matter
what you look like or where you come
from or who you love or how much money
you got
everybody's treated with dignity
everybody's treated with respect
everybody if they're willing to work
hard has a chance to make it
imagine having public officials who
who abide by the values
our mamas and our grandmas and our
grandpas taught us
being honest
being responsible working hard
looking after those who can't look after
themselves
showing compassion
believing in justice
all that is possible all that is within
our reach
for all and and the reason i know it is
is because i've seen it all across the
country every time i've gotten
discouraged
over these last four years whenever i've
seen our worst impulses revealed
i've also seen
america at its best
i've seen folks of every age and
background look out for other people
packing cities and town squares so that
families wouldn't be separated
rallying so that another classroom won't
get shot up
proclaiming that we need to do something
to make sure our kids won't grow up in
an uninhabitable planet
we we have seen health care workers risk
their lives
daily to save somebody else's loved ones
we've seen people contribute and
volunteer bring food to neighbors
help out the elderly who are alone who
are having an especially hard time right
now
we've seen americans of all races
join together to declare in the face of
injustice and brutality
that black lives matter no more but no
less
we we don't want anybody feeling
superior better than anybody else we
just want everybody to treat each other
with common decency and respect
that's all we want just basic fairness
so that no child in this country
should feel the continuing sting of
racism
and that they're judged by the content
of their character
we've seen people march all across this
country you've seen towns where
they're barely any black folks and they
still got folks marching
with signs up because they believe
that we can be better
georgia america's a good and decent
place
we've just seen so much noise and so
much nonsense
and distraction and
and we feed we've we've seen media
companies and
and politicians make a business of
making us hate each other
because it drives clicks
and drives eyeballs and so sometimes
it's hard to remember
but i'm asking you to remember what this
country can be
georgia's a better place than it used to
be
there used to be a lot of violence and
cruelty in this place
and it's a better place because some
folks went out there and made sacrifices
black and white
and america it's a better place than it
used to be
but it can be better now
but you've got to do the work it's all
up to you now
i'm asking you in your ability to
believe
in john ossoff and reverend warnock
and joe biden and kamala harris but most
importantly
your collective ability to get us out
of these dark times and help us build
back
better i'm asking you to believe in your
ability
to change america we can't
abandon the americans we're hurting
right now we can't abandon the young
people who aren't getting the education
they deserve right now
we can't abandon those young people who
are out there who inspired us this
summer
we got to channel their activism into
action
we can't just imagine a better future
we got to fight for it if you haven't
voted yet go out and vote
it's not that much to ask go out there
and vote
do this basic thing
that can make america better
tomorrow we can choose to protect health
care for our families
tomorrow we can rebuild an economy that
rewards
working americans and not just the
wealthy of us
tomorrow we can elect leaders who
reflect our best instincts
and not our worst tomorrow we can choose
hope over fear
and unity over division promise to
change over the
the power of the status quo and if we do
georgia
if we vote like our lives depend on it
because they do
we will elect john ossoff and reverend
warnock to the united states senate
we will send joe biden kamala harris to
the white house
and we will leave no doubt about who we
are
and what this country stands for
hulk if you're ready to go punk if
you're fired up
georgia let's do this
[Applause]
let's go out there and show that we
believe
god bless you god bless the united
states of america
[Music]
from the shot gun
[Music]
we take care
care
of
this
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
we take you down
[Music]